gabe did uh hear some booze
uh i would say 90 boos when his picture
went up on the big video board
anderson has not picked up a victory yet
for the phillies this is his third game
uh he was effective the last time
against the
new york mets but only went four innings
so he's gone five and four
and he needs to stretch that swag gonna
miss
95 on the fastball first strikeout for
anderson
taking them out for the giants tonight
is kevin gossman coming off for the
fourth time really been throwing like an
ace great stuff four seam high velocity
great feel for a split change when he's
right that you're gonna see a lot of
that split change
now the o2 pitch and a splitter struck
him out swinging
that's pretty impressive
fly ball center field and mickey
mourinho does not see it
it's going to wind up dropping as he
comes in he makes the catch
he came diving forward he finally was
able to see it
he got some help from the corners from
harper and mccutchen
to let him know where to go and he
showed his athleticism to come in and
make the grab
he said i thought i had no chance and
she said
i lost sight of it myself my goodness
i mean you talk about a helpless feeling
but he has
some good closing speed and makes it up
chase anderson the right-hander from the
wind-up
delivers mongoria drives this one to
right center field moniak chasing this
one is
one hop up against the right center
field wall helmet flies off for longoria
as he races to second he's going to stop
there
with a two out double and put another
one in the column for longoria
that will definitely go down as a hard
hit ball
he crushed it another extra base hit for
him
a two out double runner in scoring
position for the giants
so now belt with a chance to put the
giants ahead nothing nothing third
inning longoria at second
belt gets a breaking ball hammers it to
deep right
out of here and the giants lead two
nothing
and for belt his third of the year and
remember he hits him in bunches
you hang it we bang it he lets out some
serious shaft right there
he kept messing around with the
curveball curveball hangs the hammer and
he's
just sitting all over it drives it into
the seats
we're in the third giants two fills
nothing philly's with one hit
so far it was bryce harper singled with
two outs
in the first gosman ready in the 1-2
pitch swinging a ball pulled through the
hole a base hit they had the shift on on
the left side but the
oscars able to thread the needle between
longoria and crawford
gosman letter high comes set he kicks
the pitch
swung on lined up the middle it's past
the dive of crawford
into center field hoskins turning he's
going to try for third here's the throw
by slater it's not in time
and bryce harper is on base yet again
for the seventh straight played
appearance
jt is four for 11 with runners in
scoring position he's got two in scoring
position against gaussman here
got him had to have been the lack of
velocity that fooled remuto
richard posey was nicked up this weekend
in miami he was hit by a pitch
in his left elbow sally takes a strike
on a changeup
that's four strikeouts for chase
anderson two outs here in the fourth
and he does and a call strike three got
him with a change-up back-to-back case
for anderson
he has five through the first four
innings tonight
for the phillies and a line drive bases
into left center field
balm turns second heads to third and
sigour is on his way to second the throw
it is not in time he slid right around
the tag
second and third nobody out for the time
being
because the giants will look at it
underneath he's watching him headed to
second base
he can smell 200 doubles yeah listello
just missed him
the best swim move ever yes segora wants
the ball because that is his
200th career double that's why he wants
it video board they show 200 doubles for
gene segura
his teammates giving him a standing
ovation
and you know what he earned that and
he's earned a couple of them this year
he sure has what a baby
seven eight nine now that's where you
reach back for your best stuff
[Applause]
got him a three-pitch strikeout
[Applause]
got him and gazzali's gonna throw it at
first he
almost nipped maton in the back on the
throw there's two down
[Applause]
bounced on the ground to long gloria
he's gonna get out of it
two strikeouts and a ground ball to
third we will head to the fifth
o2 to maitan flares it out to left
center field crawford's going back and
he won't get it
it's the first big league hit for nick
natan
it comes in the bottom of the sixth
inning
here at citizens bank park
a moment he will always remember
forever and ever and ever
congratulations young man yeah brandon
belt just said something to him and nick
mayton said thank you thank you very
much
first big league hit change up he goes
with it
it's through it just enough to get it
out three and two the runners will be on
the move
bounce to third longoria
to belt gaussman does it again
fastball got him you know you usually
trick a guy with a breaking ball
you just tricked him with a fastball he
pulled a roma one and two
two down nobody on here's the set and
the pitch
fastball line to center field here comes
slater and he'll make a diving catch
leaning forward austin slater lined it
up
and he made the catch risky play
instead of playing it conservatively he
went for the catch and he made it
[Applause]
crawford's got it on the backhand solano
to first
not in time is the throw pulled belt off
the bag but they get
a very important out and a nice play by
crawford
[Applause]
got him knapp helps out
peralta one down in the ninth great
change up well executed down and away
bounce to third again longoria
to belt two down
[Applause]
bounce to third longoria
ball game so the giants come into
philadelphia
and they shut out the marlins
yesterday and what do they do they come
back and shut out the phillies